for example it really helps yeah that's
cool so this way it prevents us from
kind of overusing an agent because he's
gonna get heat now if his heat bar gets
to the max then what happens
less effective at taking their jobs his
traveling will take longer so okay okay
however if you got the money get them
with witness protection manage changes
hold very that's go wow so you got the
authentic passport the authentic
currency go very cool looks like my
co-host Lord addicts I'm gonna make a
name for him there
[Music]
okay this is the place where you
actually catch this is cool man I cannot
wait
this is this is absolutely intriguing
then when are you looking at release
summer Wow PC Xbox won't do it I cannot
wait let me ask you a question where for
us to do that the Xbox one now actually
the ps4 will there be any enhancements
as far as like from maybe from a 4k
standpoint 4matic standpoint you know
being on the on the newer kind of next
gen systems are we looking at any type
of enhancements there nice so we getting
that 4k enhancements for on the pearl
and on the Xbox one Xbox possible
huge power brokers bombur's what else we
have here
it was her good password again
[Music]
so we're looking for like certain
keywords right now okay just a few more
and then they'll be able to make the
connections touch a watershed okay
finally okay we're set to go so we found
out about this secret code name
organization Chilean Rex and there are
these actual organizations that we need
to find out which which which which of
those are referred
this is all data that we acquired in the
world yes okay tactical strategic should
linear apps I thought we saw them right
wasn't it right there in the center or
no yeah when do you have a magic one
okay didn't see it yeah dividend how
could seniors golf course
[ __ ] be hornet's nest chain-smoker
hornet's nest chain smoker
Oh again here's our connection this
could be bogus watershed what is it okay
I think we're done here and so we
couldn't dodge and this enemy that's
revealed to Ellen what's up like that
that now it becomes a target in the game
if you encountered him and the mission
also agentless okay so we'd kind of turn
however in MKULTRA which is our last
facility for example
for example the guy put them back out in
the world yeah and what does that do to
use that control phrase and then drink
the mission right I remember yeah so
that's wow that is really cool so
clearly that age it is it will be
expendable at that voice right so we
looked at one bar one stone we got a big
sacrifice I love that abilities and
things that you can do here man I would
love actually I could do this interview
all all them today I got a role get a
catch my food but um do i I'm absolutely
loving the game it seems fantastic and
you said release will be this summer yes
summer the game will be
console we are very happy camera I'm
keeping my eye on fan of doctrine this
is one of my highlights out of the
shorty 3 I wanted to get the hands on
with it absolute pleasure to have you
absolutely managed phantom phantom
doctrine y'all this one's cool